a lot of times we like to portray
ourselves as victims women and
particularly in the dating world and I
feel like as a true conservative I have
to take responsibility for some of the
the situations that I got myself in hi
I'm Nicolas be with reason TV and today
we're talking with Lisa DiPasquale she
is the author of the memoir of dating in
DC in the conservative world finding
mister righteous Lisa thanks for talking
to us thanks for having me what prompted
you to write this erotic well you know
if Ann Coulter calls you racy you put it
on the cover of your book and that's
what I did for me I the story was about
my sort of religious journey over the 15
years I've been in DC and I used some of
the men that I've dated in those years
to tell the story and we'll talk a
little bit about the religious journey
you you showed up here in you know 99
2000 what were you religiously and then
where are you now well I showed up I
guess as a Christian I named only in
that if someone said what are you I say
Oh much a Christian I guess and then I
was an atheist or agnostic sort of
buried on the day and then about two or
three years ago I became a Christian and
by that do you mean a kind of born-again
evangelical Christian um I guess so I
mean the church that I go to I don't pay
attention to you know what it is it's
more that I just like that in one of
your discussion of the book you talked
about how you were at CPAC and you
organized CPAC for a while and did very
well with that in the 2000s and had a
falling out over the gay rights issue
right go crowd go crowds inclusion but
at one point you know that's a place
where there aren't that many women and
there are a lot of men and somebody
remark that of it the odds are finding a
date here and he said well you know the
odds are good but the goods are odd yes
talk a little bit about that is there so
what is the peculiar oddity of
conservative men well you know I think
particularly in the movement and
probably in particular in DC or other
large cities is that people lead with
their job and there were times when you
know I tried online dating and
you know I would hear from someone for
instance who was like a 99% match and I
finally get an email from him and he
says can you get me on a CPAC panel yeah
and that's good opening line well I
suppose but you know I think for a lot
of guys at a Tennessee PAC they're there
for different reasons and for a majority
of them it's you know to get their name
out there to speak you know something to
meet other people but I think it's the
girls that think Oh CPAC is a good place
to meet you know a significant other
that more than the guys think that right
here's a question you know do
conservative men objectify women in a
way that is you know do they either put
them on a pedestal or do they objectify
them or dismiss them as not
intellectually serious in any way or in
any proportion that's distinct from your
understanding of how liberal or
libertarian or you know nihilistic men
treat women well I mean having known
someone like Ann Coulter for a long time
I mean certainly I've seen it on the
Left how people portray her and talk
about her looks or whatever I think we
do the same when it comes to Hillary or
Claire McCaskill or women like that but
I think a majority of the conservative
men that I see a lot of them like to
talk about like how hot women on our
side are you there's like a graphic that
goes around that shows like these are
these they're women these are our women
there's a lot of conservative guys that
are always bragging about their hot wife
so I kind of think it's probably more of
like these are the dorky kids in high
school and they want to brag about how
now they have a hot wife Wow what effect
do you hope to have on the culture by
writing finding mr. righteous before the
average reader on the dating message I
would hope that they would take away
from it that you know you can't have a
redemption story with like a lot of bad
stuff happening and you know a lot of
times we like to portray ourselves as
victims women and particularly in in the
dating world and I feel like as a true
conservative I have to take
responsibility for some of the the
situations that I got myself in and you
know particularly when it comes to
dating that you know you're going to get
what you give
so this is if I read if I heard you
correctly you're basically saying that
you a you cannot be saved until you've
sinned in
Israeli a rewriting of Augustine's
plea to make me you know make me
continent but not yet everything in
moderation including moderation
okay well we'll leave it there and the
book is finding mr. righteous the author
who is with us today on reason TV is
Lisa DiPasquale thanks so much for
talking to thank you for reason TV I'm
Nick Gillespie